ah very nice to meet you pleasure my guy
how are you great but flopped with a
powder-blue my across the street from
the spot please crowded suit lines
there's confirmation it's like the stuff
that she already maybe knew in your gut
100% well you you were pushing towards
it's like okay like I'm not the only one
who feels like this I'm not crazy
um yes so you write about like some
people that know diagram it is someone
who I known and work with a bit and it
was dope it's just like it's great to
have it as a resource that as a reminder
that should not the only one in the
world fails like this I totally agree
I think affirmation is like you know
yeah and just like look to me I always
just think like if you have one nuance
it's gold you know so what's going on
nothing they're just working and I'm
trying to balance it and you know the
passion and the business mm-hmm how's it
going great you know when I start a
couple of months ago I started about
last year I started a better music you
know I've been doing journalism well I
know the genius way and all that yeah so
but I started the music last year we
were actually supposed to meet I don't
know if you remember this we were
supposed to meet last year and Mike was
trying to set it up and I had to cancel
because you were making the transition
yeah well what happened was logic call
me yes all at the Barclays I said yo do
you want to come onstage with me you're
like yeah but I said nah man that was
the right guy that would [ __ ] cancel
that yeah that's amazing I was in the
ground I saw I saw him bring you out
yeah
you made the right choice me that was a
packed house what do you mean what do me
make the right choice oh my god that's
huge how'd it feel
it felt great cuz I'm from Flatbush
Brooklyn so now I'm aware places right
now Flatbush Avenue it's crazy
um you must have been just like what the
[ __ ] I wasn't even there when I was a
kid imagine by now when you're a kid
somebody says yo we're gonna take
Madison Square Garden and put it right
on Flatbush Avenue in or your favorite
artist
form there and you'll perform that one
there I wouldn't even that's just crazy
I used to battle on that corner a flat
was it yeah because I went to school
that broken attack on the way home from
school who's the person that roasted you
the most and your battle in the history
or life on that corner we know we know
MIT was it on that corner
nobody roasted me on that corner like
that I was like but I I definitely used
to battle and there's an MC people know
I don't know if you heard of his name's
the immortal technique yes destroyed
yeah he destroyed me just huh yeah
there's not here this day and you didn't
have your day it's like a boxing match
you know no at the time he was just
better than period is just period we got
it oh you just went up in weight class
yeah yeah but you know I wasn't how'd
you feel when I lost yeah I mean it's
stung but I love it I love it I knew he
was better than me yeah so you were
looking for an upset yeah I wasn't salty
well what happened was I didn't have a
choice you know when you're challenging
and you're been and people were watching
we weren't yeah called the wetlands it
doesn't exist anymore but we're in the
basement of this club and everybody's
watching like well you gotta go for it
100% cuz cuz he alternatives way worse
yeah
and getting knocked out is a hell of a
lot worse than leaving the ring and with
a lot better excuse me is he and I were
friends before that and so I liked it it
was fun to me you took it to light he
took it seriously I get it I'm the same
so look in his eyes like he was ya know
me in that moment and that's so funny
more all my friends growing up always
were like would say that about me when
we play things they're like like I would
just I literally thought like a backyard
basketball game was like [ __ ] like
nineteen like Roman Empire like if I
lose this game one-on-one like I die
right right
that's how I do everything still yeah I
get that that makes a lot of sense to me
man and but what I found is in my career
journalism I approach it very much the
same way
mm-hm when I'm creating content when I'm
doing so
the best interview with the best yeah
that's exactly right now like if blah
blah blah had the best interview ever
you're like [ __ ] that yeah I'm gonna get
something out of this guy that he's
never said before I have the best
Kendrick Lamar interview ever you know
saying I have the best 21 Savage
interview ever like you know like this
is how I fail it I dare anybody to say
something different or do better yeah we
took 21 Savage I took him to a
blacksmith with genius and and I changed
to come and he has the nice tattoo on
his head and we've recreated the nice
testament to our actual knife got an
actual blacksmith to do it and through
that we had a conversation about what
the tattoo means to him him growing up
why he raps the way he raps it's the
reason you look you're a storyteller
right no it's amazing you know it's
funny that you realized that when I made
the transition so the thing was I grew
up and I always used to rap I thought I
was gonna be a rapper first the problem
was that you know I had my first son how
old four year well now you owe me I'm 38
right so and rap wasn't paying the bills
and journalism came knocking and I was
like I'm not turned in this check now
and I got bills to pay I got mouths to
feed
um when I got into the industry I still
would do music but I was made to feel
like I was doing something wrong you
couldn't be a journalist and do music at
the same same preaching I literally was
almost fired why he was trapped SS out
mm-hmm because they didn't understand it
and when it came time to choose the
music which was the passion or the money
of paying the bills he took the money
a handsome like you're not my man
everybody does why do you think the
people that don't get put on a pedestal
yeah yeah you know I was just afraid of
animal no no no no for me my guy of
course we don't tape of course but what
happens is now and there's a million
versions of that story absolutely
there's a person who decides to rob
somebody and goes to jail for three
years there's a million versions of that
story the reason the person that doesn't
choose those paths goes and is one of
the
you people that gets through is put on a
pedestal it's because 99% don't even try
and 99% of the 1% don't make it right
but what happened to me was you know I
was good at journalism yeah great cuz it
was the same [ __ ] game right and this
is what I realized cuz it's storytelling
they're going hundred percent like that
you said it's all storytelling now I get
to a point in my journalism career where
I'm at genius and you know the data
doctors are ingenious every rapper worth
talking about was tweeting about me
moving the genius you know Meek Mill had
tweeted about it and this was three days
at after back-to-back he wasn't on
Twitter for those three days but he
tweeted to say yo congratulations Rob
congratulations this is dope so great
man that's so [ __ ] awesome what I
realized at that point was um it's time
to follow the passion and even write
that in there maybe not at them but that
became the scene but but first of all
I'm at a point in journalism where
nobody's gonna fire me for making music
really what it came down to us I had
accomplished everything in my life I
accomplished more than I thought I could
in that field yeah
but in life yeah I get it more than I
thought I could more than I think a lot
of people gave me credit for when I was
growing up sure when I didn't want to
look back in my life and not do the one
thing that I always wanted it's a Capri
a Mac which was making it and honestly
brought do it honestly I think the
biggest confusion of the way people
consume my content is I believe in the
way that you did it more than the way
that people interpret what I'm telling
them to do is people hear the part of my
content that says go jump quit your job
they don't hear the practical part they
don't then they didn't hear the other
part of the sentence which was if you're
willing to live in a shittier situation
in the short term to give you you could
have made the jump but you and your girl
and your baby would have had an even
shittier you coulda you didn't have to
take the check from XXL you could have
kept going that one that big that's
right you could have worked at the
[ __ ] right you know but you could
have worked at the boat day huh yukata
you could have [ __ ] played CeeLo in
the corner
why to win yet you coulda you could have
moved in with your mom's you could have
they hear the jump they don't hear that
but everything else besides the jump is
about to get worse
the 22 year olds hear me say yo this is
the practical huh time to jump all these
kids that are [ __ ] on their parents
because of my content don't hear the
part that I agree with their parents on
which is wait so Oh kid who I just paid
college for well you're telling me some
[ __ ] [ __ ] Gary be on the internet
said don't get a job and now you're
gonna be a rapper cool but I'm not
giving you any more money these kids
hear it and they're like they want moms
and dads to still give them $1,000
Starbucks card or pay for the gym so so
people are here in the part they want to
hear from me that's why so many people
don't [ __ ] with me at first because I'm
putting pressure on them and they go
rather listen to some other [ __ ]
person who said I want to be coddled
people do not want to be held
accountable people do not want to eat
[ __ ] people people want to prove
everybody wrong without doing the work
to prove everybody wrong people think
like I'm not going to get a job after 22
and put entrepreneur in my headline and
that's the win I saw it in Silicon
Valley - the wind was raising the money
you grew up in the genius scale like you
got it right like you saw Twitter 2010
through 15 congratulations just like
when you left congratulations you raised
three million dollars I was like so
that's when the pressure starts that's
what now you got a there's a bloomberg
video d-roc I want to [ __ ] edit it in
here right now in this rant I want it up
I want the whole [ __ ] thing I know
you got a lot of good content today I
want a lot of it I'm on [ __ ]
Bloomberg and everybody's cheering it's
this [ __ ] TechStars competition and
some dude goes you know everyone else
was like talking about [ __ ] I raise
money no I'm sorry I raise money I raise
money I raise money and everyone and
dude goes we haven't raised any money
we've been making money and everyone's
quiet and I lose my [ __ ]
I'm like this why this whole [ __ ]
thing's broken [ __ ] you Gary let me
start off with you on this then
[Laughter]
balancing between fundraising and
building your business what do you look
for to see you um you know I'm concerned
a little bit with the culture of
celebrating the fundraise you know my
dad taught me that when you borrow money
it's the worst day of your life
so I'm very interested in the
entrepreneurs I like you know we didn't
clap for Red Rover because they didn't
raise six trillion dollars but I was
sitting here like good stuff
I just filtered myself so you know you
know what I'm looking for is people that
are not caught up in the excitement even
though I'm a hype man myself
I like the practicality of it all people
that understand how to turn a profit I
mean at the end of the day this is still
business right and so I'm looking for
real practical knowledge of how to
actually make money not necessarily
raise it that's crazy
it's worst people aren't here in the
part to matter but the one thing that I
will say because I don't want people to
take it
I love journalism so I loved working at
double-xl I was part of you ready for
this was that I think you're gonna still
do journalism
absolutely well the plan the plan is not
so quick of course you don't have to the
part that people understand is this
[ __ ] internet thing gave you options
and and even where I'm at now with the
music is I'm trying to find I build a
fan base for my journalism I built the
following I built into place in two
places in the b2b and the b2c yeah you
understand yeah the biggest thing you
built was the b2b love because that's
why you understood all the barclays of
course yeah that's why I'm hoping
therefore to change that Terminal five
like I know 100% and but now it's like
not wasting those opportunities well
listen you're not gonna waste them
because you got lucky and we're brought
up in a way to not understand how to
waste them you just might not be
talented enough your thing isn't gonna
be the wasted you weren't coddled and
fed you were hungry you've got the hard
part down now it just depends how
talented you are you know think honestly
that's what's kind of cool
and that's that's what you want is a
shot 100% like look and this this record
isn't out yet I haven't done any
features yes you know I have a bunch of
that friends that haven't done any
peaches I have a record is done I'm
gonna put down a couple of weeks with
featuring style P style speak to me when
you talk about rap is one of the most
technically skilled rappers around like
the craft yeah I feel like I held my own
I feel like I got on that record with
him and whether you like my first better
than his or his burns better than mine I
belong like you're gonna hear it you're
gonna be like oh wow like I see why this
is where he's going and that's why he
wanted to do it absolutely yeah it makes
sense it's the right strategy absolutely
in with our playlist the reason I just
pulled my phone out like I post up the
playlist like I do every week the only
comment was someone wrote long fly home
truly struck me really appreciate you
putting me on
that's his song there's a last song on
our playlist this week and it's his song
and like he was telling me how heroes
storyteller storyteller listen man for
his flight listen listen it's the only
reason you know me I like comic books
episode 1 of course your your story
brother the only reason I'm even sitting
the only reason I'm sitting here is cuz
when juicy came out I started to
understand why I liked it
cuz biggie was painting such a cleaner
[ __ ] story in that [ __ ] song and I
at 18 years old was like oh that's what
I like up into that point with [ __ ]
you know dr. Dre and too short and
[ __ ] Beastie Boys and fat boys and
you know like Harris one I didn't know I
was like it's cool I'm for medicine it's
tough but that that song came out I knew
exactly what his room looked like I knew
exactly what was happening and I was
like and forever my relationship with
the genre changed I don't even
understand music I'm being dead serious
like all these producers and everything
like beats and everything I'm like yes
like I understand the thesis of like
like you know hit when hypnotized comes
on and you're that parent like I get
that that makes me what like I get that
but I don't [ __ ] with it
you know what it is I want to hear what
the person's gonna say you did you do on
this
because it's a feeling so no again I
understand right but I understand if
it's off the [ __ ] rocker and like
everybody understands and it comes on
and everyone in the club goes and
everyone's dance I understand but out of
like a thousand songs right now of
really good producers I'm not gonna
understand nine hundred ninety four of
them because they're just gonna be great
but what I'm and understand is what
people are saying like when Big KRIT is
what big kids trying to say to me what
Rallo is saying in that song young bands
I [ __ ] with him because of that I like
what he's saying he's and he's still a
kid and he's got [ __ ] pain inside of
him and he's like I can hear it that's
why you're gonna win you know it was
funny that you say that the record
that's on the monday the monday played
this long flight home like I was
literally in LAX my flight got delayed I
just wanted to be home and the flight
kept getting pushed back and I was
looking frustrated and my producer has
sent me three beats I'm like let me just
check out these beats I checked out the
first one first ten seconds up I don't
like it
second one first ten seconds I don't
like it the beat for long flight home
came one I think was called winter story
was the name of the beat before let's go
I played it and I was like holy [ __ ]
this beat is the exact move that I meant
let's go let's go
so I started running on the spot in LAX
sitting down waiting for my plane I
stopped writing I look to my right and I
see a clutch a coach touch pick it up
and is this anybody's it snow wagons I
look at this five hundred Aza net ID
credit cards I'm like holy [ __ ] let the
old me would have kept that but I said
man I took it to the gate and said look
somebody left this you know and I'm
thinking I'm like you know like I mean
that's not my [ __ ] that could be the
student loan that could be that car note
you know whatever I sit back down to
write the song and forgot where I was
that so I'm like where do I pick up so
oh I'm gonna pick up with what just
happened
I found the clutch we found hunting it
you know it just turned it into the gate
you know like and I'm from there listen
listen look
the [ __ ] I'm doing I think that's the
number one thing people should do is
tell the truth and document the [ __ ]
journey I don't think there's any first
you know any people actually this is
actually to talk to music people I think
I understand like I think a couple more
years I'm gonna be like really helping
people in music let me explain the first
projects easy that's a whole lots of
writing got lights worth a story he's
got it my first keynote of course it was
perfect I'm like I'm a boy from Belarus
I wrote a [ __ ] like lemonade and it
hit it hit it hit because it was easy
I didn't realize of course I didn't have
slides of course I was spitting from the
top I was just telling you who the [ __ ]
I was and what I was thinking about but
I told you what I was for the first 20
minutes and the reason they all [ __ ]
with me after a while because there's
only so many times you can hear about
the baseball cards was and then I told
you about what was happening right now
and so to me a lot of artists kill that
first project and they become one-hit
wonders or one project superstars cuz
they don't realize they want to tell a
story which means they're making up [ __ ]
right but what they need to tell you is
like what the [ __ ] happened when you
made the transition from the streets to
the businessman trying to negotiate with
you so you point that first like where's
that like laughs and that's in that song
long flight home so let's talk about
again because of my relationships when I
dropped my first EP last year everybody
expected me to have a bunch of features
because I had a great relationship right
I didn't want a bunch of features
because you thought of strategically
like cool then I got but I'm gonna keep
it real there was some guys that I asked
for features who didn't take me
seriously and they just fueled something
fire and I never wanted to admit that
because it made me feel like no I was
lesser no no no more you're more that's
me I'm I'm driven I'm I I all I want is
negative comments right
it drives you I love that but the
funniest thing is the people that give
me love in this comment section I love
them I love them like my I love my
mother right
but the people that love leave me
negative comments they don't realize
they think they're tearing me down your
[ __ ] feeding me you [ __ ]
you're feeding me your [ __ ] food you
so not smart you actually I only feel
two things you're so not smart you're
feeding me I'm gonna get bigger and
badder because of what you're doing and
then number two I feel bad for you so
sorry for those I feel bad for you you
really have so much pain in your life
that you've taken time out of being on
the offense to come to me and tell me
something bad I hate that your mom
[ __ ] up like I'm like something
happened you know what's a little I
apologize for cutting you up the one
weird thing about me that I'm the thing
about me that probably the culture likes
the thing it's weird with me though is
if I were you if I was living your exact
life right now after by pastor I was
accepted as like that skilled I would
destroy those [ __ ] on wax oh all
right and I mean in a fun cuz are your
friends in a fun way like I'm very
chippy [ __ ] right so I'm ready to like
I'm not really battles have got more of
a storyteller but this is hip-hop and as
competitive as a bless the best I'm
ready I'm always ready to but honestly
unlike what you did there I'm keeping it
all inside all of it and the truth is I
keep it inside because the good news is
99.9% of it goes away right but man do I
feel bad for those point one right cuz
their feelings would be hurt forever but
you know I'm trying to I'm trying to do
generational hurt I'm trying to build
generation like I'm just thinking about
the point one there's two or three
people on a list
I'm and their kids are gonna get hurt
like everyone like me and I
and I thought but you know me it's
because they really like doing the wrong
thing is the wrong and and not honestly
there used to be seven people on the
list but enough time went on like my
hope is that it never happens yeah yeah
yeah you know what it is I'm just
competitive and the big thing for me is
just like it's like it's it's really
funny like it's funny I can actually now
I'm gonna talk it out for real I'll
never do it I never how many times have
you seen you hurt somebody it's just not
in me but it's on it it's it's it's on
the Shelf and it feeds me because I want
to stick in people's mouths the greatest
feeling is the look there's been plenty
of times in business when somebody's
looked at me and I've looked at them and
we know the exact story that happened
seven years ago you punk me and said I
was gonna be [ __ ] I [ __ ] crushed and
three years ago I [ __ ] helped your
sister and the one year ago you
acknowledged it subliminally and now
we're both looking at each other and I'm
like see I'm a bigger man than you you
[ __ ] I'm a bigger man than you I saw
video yesterday that vaynermedia made
then I'm in they spelled my name wrong
but I like it I appreciate where you
come from in a lot of ways you know my
EP was called right to dream and because
I'm a writer I started out as a journal
that's call you RIT thanks Irene but but
the real message is I have a right to
dream you have a right to dream you have
a right you know my man my man do you
know why it matters the most right now
why I'm putting out so much [ __ ] if you
were writing for the source in 1994 if
you were literally born 20 years earlier
and we're writing for this source you
wouldn't be in the music industry today
because you would how to get signed you
like the end right they like Empire and
Spotify and YouTube and our playlet they
don't people don't get it a right to
dream was aspirational and ideological
50 years ago it's just not anymore
that's crazy honestly like I can't
believe that [ __ ] a kid right now is
gonna get hyped off of this record on
some bullsh on his phone on her phone
uploaded to SoundCloud man sellout
[ __ ] Madison Square Garden in nine
years
you know honestly I'm in a position
because of the journalism I don't have
to monetize the music I got it
um I want some monetizing music and I
want to grow it as many wells but I
don't want to skip any steps I get it so
I'm building a base so money is not
really an issue it is for the love but
the most rewarding thing more than a
check and you know I've gotten a couple
checks off the ratchet is cool but the
most rewarding thing the love the love
is this yo
that person yeah yeah who are you
talking to
that's all I've defaulted into right
don't and then those people you know
they always say people might not
remember what exactly what you said to
them but they'll always remember how you
made them feel
my Angela yeah and those people so what
race that book whoever becomes the the
next big rapper what becomes the next
big journalist they're never gonna
forget who inspired them and my man
you're part of that network my man it's
the only thing I think about I I
absolutely know I will be the greatest
entrepreneur of this era because I'm
gonna win on the two fronts that people
gonna judge by I'll make enough money so
that I'm in the conversation and I will
[ __ ] and inspire and help more
entrepreneurs than the rest of the field
combined I'm talking all of them because
what Elon Musk does in his actions to
inspire is incredible it's incredible
and Steve Jobs and then but what I'm
doing is different and I know it
the end cuz and by the way it's cuz I
want it more something I'm better I just
want that that's the part I want I'm
it's what this whole thing is that's why
the document like people don't you
understand when I'm actually doing that
I'm leaving somewhat like from a
businessman see but I'm leaving so much
money on the table
what money's not to go no you know
what's funny for me money stop being the
goal at $100,000 I couldn't believe I
made a hundred thousand dollars a year I
was like that was it and since then
nothing's been the same doesn't feel the
same
not a million not ten million doesn't
feel the same one hundred thousand five
bucks when I cut see this see this scar
mm-hmm
I was the ring boy in my in a relative's
wedding and Jewish people step on the
glass I was the oldest of the kids I was
like nine everyone so six and five I was
the Alpha run everybody round be
ridiculous I was like yo let's go find
the glass I found it I went and grabbed
it
cut the [ __ ] out of my hand we were
still pretty poor back then like nothing
like real like it's poor it middle class
lower low or middle class and my dad
gave me five bucks to go home with my
great-grandmother cuz I didn't want to
leave that was the best day of my life
I've never told that story that was that
five I looked at that five dollar bill
my whole life I think like like for six
years I looked at it it felt like so
much now I don't even know how to
because ATMs don't give anything less
than 20 I - you know this I tip 20 for
everything and it's really funny because
I don't want to I think 10 is more
applicants um times I'm not the best guy
ever but I just don't have them on me
top me go okay I got a bounce Thank You
Man listen keep hitting us up we want to
giv love I'm very fascinated by I loved
the track like loved it and I so saw the
storytelling you know
[Music]